[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau gilles casanova spécialiste en
communication politique bonsoir gilles
casanova merci d'être avec nous à vos
côté alexis poulain à bonne distance
bonsoir alexis poulain du temps et lis
tes france merci d'être là et puis avec
nous en direct aussi pour nous
accompagner philippe gosselin député l
ère de la manche bonsoir avoue vincent
chauvet également maire modem d'autun
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous de également
alors une réaction à cette polémique ça
parlant depuis hier la classe politique
est en gros mise à part le modem et la
raim vent debout depuis l'annnonce par
tf1 de cette émission spéciale en prime
time l'opposition fustige cette
intervention l'a entendu c'est une
interview alexis d'un candidat non
déclaré c'est tout le problème le
problème il est il est multiple le
problème c'est que et mener le maquereau
on ne peut pas passer une semaine sans
capter l'attention des médias pour
phagocyter finalement tout ce qui ferait
une campagne présidentielle la semaine
dernière le lendemain deux grands
meetings il arrive pour déambuler à
vierzon et pour sortir un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire bon ben là
cette semaine on est en train de parler
d'autre chose il ya des déplacements de
candidats il a besoin de deux heures
d'interviews de complaisance sur une
chaîne de grande écoute enfin deux
heures une interview enregistrée qui
plus est même pas dans des conditions du
direct la semaine dernière il faisait
une conférence de presse pour parler de
la présidence européenne du conseil de
présidence française du conseil européen
je veux dire c'est pas les candidats
dans cette campagne ne joue pas à armes
égales c'est à dire que vous avez face à
vous un président de la république
omniprésent qui utilisent les médias qui
sont en plus des médias très complaisant
et des candidats qui se battent pour
faire connaître leurs campagnes yannick
jadot il y avait un sondage récemment
qui disait que 50 % des français
interrogés n'était même pas au courant
qu'il était en campagne
vous avez un président même s'il n'est
pas candidat de toute façon vous l'avez
matin midi et soir à la télévision il
est là le problème il est là le problème
c'est que fondamentalement il ya un
problème c'est totalement déséquilibrée
et valérie pécresse tout comme yannick
jadot ont raison de saisir le csa ce
n'est pas normal que le président
utilise des médias de cette façon là on
parle de propagande ici on parle pas du
tout d'interviews d'un chef de l'état
gilles cazade avant on parle de
propagande avant évidemment d'aller
poser la question aussi aux aux
intéressés par ce que franck philippe
gosselin sanaa bien énervé aussi cet
après midi on va en reparler mais
rapidement il ya un déséquilibre c'est
une forme de propagande et on vous par
megal alors la règle du cssa c'est un
tiers de temps de parole pour la
majorité un tiers pour l'opposition
un tiers pour le gouvernement le
président de la république n'est pas
dans les décomptes du csa il parle où il
veut quand il veut autant qu'il veut
cependant lorsque s'ouvre la période
électorale le csa des comptes dans les
propos du président ce qui ressort de
son rôle de président par exemple
'l'annonce d'un confinement ou d'inde et
confinement est ce qui ressort de la
campagne électorale par exemple
l'annnonce de sa vision du monde ce qui
est l'objectif des deux heures qu'il
fait sur tf1 et lci là on peut
considérer que ces deux heures là elles
vont être dans le compte de campagne
s'il est candidat alors évidemment par
exemple françois hollande n'ayant pas
été candidat la partie que le csa avait
retenu est tombé dans la corbeille mais
pour les autres en général on a fait
entrer ce temps mais il faut avoir en
tête la jurisprudence du csa exprimée
par son président en 2002
le csa considère qu'il a des candidats
de premier tour et des candidats de
second tour et
donc le président du csa a dit la veille
du premier tour nous avons fait notre
travail puisque un tiers du temps est
allé à lionel jospin un tiers du temps
est allé à jacques chirac et un tiers du
temps à tous les autres candidats vous
voyez comment la méthode du csa qui a
retiré la parole
sur la chronique qu'il faisait à eric
zemmour est une méthode
un peu difficile à cerner alors philippe
gosselin mousse on a vu cet après midi
que ça vous a bien embêtés on a assisté
une passe d'armes l assemblée nationale
avec le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriel à thann je vous laisse découvrir
ça avant de vous donner la parole
cinq ans plus tard ce nouveau monde nous
paraît pire il faut le dire que l'ancien
votre majorité finalement reproduit et
même accentuée tous les travers
politique qu'elle dénonce it hier
l'émission qui sera diffusée demain soir
et bien une émission de campagne ni plus
ni moins personne le citron sauf que le
président refuse de s'appliquer à lui
même les règles sur les temps de parole
puis doivent pourtant respecté tous les
autres candidats monsieur le député
gosselin quand on cherche à convaincre
les français on cherche alors parlez pas
empêché les autres de le faire
quand on cherche à convaincre les
français on cherche la cohérence vous
êtes en train de dire l'exact inverse de
ce que vous disiez il y a dix ans quand
vous défendiez à raison la légitimité du
président sarkozy a parlé de son action
face à la crise jusque tard en 2012
alors philippe gosselin je sais que
richard ferrand ne vous a pas donné le
temps de la troisième réponse à vous
lire vous allez avoir la parole qu'est
ce que vous auriez envie de lui répond
en droit gabriela attal va écouter on
peut pas dire on empêche le président de
la république de s'exprimer je crois
qu'en ce moment il se surexprime il se
susurre exprime en tant que président en
tant que futur président de l'europe en
tant que candidat qui annonce 40e de
mesures pour 45 milliards d'euros qui
sont pas financées il est présent sur le
terrain dans le nord dans le sud il est
partout et systématiquement à des
périodes où les oppositions en tout cas
une partie de l'opposition peut
s'exprimer dont on voit bien que tout
est fait pour court circuiter c'est pas
un débat d'idées
c'est une omniprésence qui devient
envahissante et on veut aussi
dénoncé finalement une une focalisation
des moyens alors c'est pas c'est pas
nouveau qu'un président ne soit pas
encore en campagne et profite un peu de
la situation c'est ce qui avait amené
valérie pécresse je ne dis pas le
contraire il y a dix ans à défendre
nicolas sarkozy sauf que sauf que le csa
avait introduit dans le temps de parole
du candidat sarkozy par la suite ce
temps de pré campagne parce qu'il le
sait les saints avaient estimé que
nicolas sarkozy était candidat présumé
eh bien écoutez nous on aimerait qu'ils
soient claires et que le président de la
république assume de qu'il soit
clairement considéré comme candidat
présumé et ils ne bénéficient pas de
moyens qui prive finalement l'expression
démocratique des autres candidats ça a
été très bien dit il y à quelques
minutes sur votre plateau c'est
totalement déséquilibrée aujourd'hui
vincent chauvet vous venez d'entendre de
trois intervenants
effectivement philippe gosselin porte
parole devait les périples qui est prêt
pécresse pardon qui demande au csa donc
de rétablir clairement l'égalité du
temps de parole ça vous semblerez juste
tout de même
moi je pense que cette position c'est
une double insulte et c'est un procès
d'intention c'est une insulte d'abord
aujourd'hui ce de tf1 tf1 c'est un média
privé et jusqu'à preuve du contraire ce
n'est pas une télévision d'état une
télévision aux ordres donc ils ont envie
de passer le présent d'un public qui le
passe je remarque anne hidalgo s'est
invitée à 14h pour le 20 heures le soir
elle a eu libre antenne dans la journée
par ailleurs c'est une insulte aussi à
l'intelligence des membres du csa une
autorité administrative indépendante
moi je m'étonne qu'une candidats les
républicains et valérie pécresse tu
fasse pression sur une autorité
administrative indépendante pour prendre
décision le csa n'a pas besoin de mines
monsieur jadot ning madame pécresse pour
appliquer son mandat appliquer la loi et
fera ce que la loi est prévu si madame
pécresse
mais confie pas pardonnez moi mais
c'était quand même important quand
philippe gosselin rappelle que nicolas
sarkozy avait été considérée par le csa
comme un candidat présumé pourquoi ne
pas appliquer la même règle à emmanuel
macron
le cob le csa jeu et nicolas sarkozy
était intervenu en janvier est
aujourd'hui le président de la
république est décomptée quand il parle
du régalien donc à pas et quand il parle
d'autre chose décomptés dans le temps de
parole de la majorité gouvernementale
donc il est faux de dire qu'aujourd'hui
le temps de parole où tu es dans la
public est complètement débridée qui
pourrait exploiter 24 heures sur 24 les
chaînes d'info c'est faux le csa
applique en fonction de l'échéance qui
se rapproche des règles de plus en plus
strictes et à la fin c'est une égalité
stricte sur la période officielle de
campagne on est sur une égalité stricte
entre tous les candidats et c'est là
même si valérie pécresse le change et
qu'elle propose une nouvelle loi c'est
parce que j'ai entendu j'ai entendu des
formes de pression sur le csa et enfin
c'est surtout un procès d'intention
parce que moi personnellement je n'ai
pas lu cette interview personne autour
de la table ni valérie pécresse je pense
n'a vu cette interview et personne ne
peut préjuger de ce que le présent la
république va dire ou à annoncer moi
j'ai envie d'entendre dans une période
qui est très compliquée avec vous avez
cité des tensions géopolitiques
importante des craintes qui est sûr
c'est témoin gérant vie en tant que
citoyen simplement d'entendre ce que le
président à dire on a soupé pendant un
mois de délai matin midi et soir sur
toutes les chaînes d'info en continu moi
j'ai envie d'entendre que présente la
république a à dire et ensuite le csa à
pitre à la loi et des contrats mais j'ai
pas l'impression que emmanuel macron
squattent les chaînes d'info il fait des
déplacements en province qui sont tout à
fait intéressant par exemple sur le
programme avec son coeur de ville il
rien et c'est son rôle dans les
séquences mémorielle dans les
commémorations que nous allons les
hommages nationaux personnes éminentes
décédé et line exposé c'est bien on
verra ce qu'il a à dire
appréhender ce qu'il a annoncé on va
vous redonner la fin évidemment vincent
chauvet on va regarder le premier
message télégramme qui nous parvient
luisi 22 arrêtons l'hypocrisie les
autres ont fait aussi où le ferai aussi
la question est comment concilier l'état
de candidats et celui de président tout
en restant dans l'équité peut-être en se
déclarant alexis poulain je vous voyais
tous les trois il est vrai un vincent
chauvet faire des petits bons quand le
monde de la majorité nous exposer ses
arguments
rapidement
non mais le problème c'est pas un
problème d'arguties juridiques sur le
travail que fait le csa ne fait pas le
problème il est structurelle c'est de
dire qu'on a en france un président
candidat on n'a pas ce moment des
primaires à l'américaine où de toute
façon le président sortant est obligé de
faire campagne là on se retrouve dans
quelque chose ou non seulement le
président convoque la presse quand il
est en déplacement c'est uniquement pour
prendre la presse à partie pour qu'on
parle de lui les conseils de défense
sanitaire qu'on arrête de me faire
croire que le conseil de lundi n'étaient
pas là pour débrancher les meetings
d'eric zemmour et jean luc mélenchon le
lendemain là c'est pareil deux heures
d'interview sur tf1 c'est une interview
de campagne pour faire le bilan en plus
de son quinquennat seul sens sans que
sont le sens la conférence de presse
c'est un président qui n'a jamais paf
jamais fait de conférence de presse
quasiment 3 conférence de presse pendant
cinq ans c'est du jamais vu c'est à dire
qu'il ya une façon de maltraiter les
médias d'utiliser les médias comme de la
communication comme une agence de com ça
c'est pas possible et en plus il ya les
réseaux sociaux et ça c'est vrai qu'on
en parle parce que le csa n'a aucune
juridiction là dessus et le maquereau a
très bien dit tik tok instagram les
réseaux pour la jeunesse sont la clé
aussi de cette élection et d'autres
candidats essayent de jouer sur ces
réseaux sociaux et là il n'ya pas des
comptes de temps de parole et c'est
pareil c'est l'omniprésence donc il faut
vraiment à un moment de trouver de
nouvelles règles du jeu et puis ne pas
être dupe
les journalistes de tf1 sont très
contents d'avoir emmanuel macron
évidemment c'est le président la
république mais on est en campagne on
est en temps de campagne donc c'est tout
à fait différent quand tant de
quinquennat où il serait là pour
s'expliquer sur ce qui s'est passé cette
année gilles casanova justement vous
êtes communiquant politique vous lui
auriez conseillé à emmanuel la france
qui vous avez été dans son équipe deux
justement enregistré cette émission et
surtout la sphère diffusé le jour où
valérie pécresse était supposé être sur
une autre chaîne à la lieu d'ailleurs se
décaler de lui si j'étais conseiller je
dirais qu'il faut pas faire écrire les
éléments de langage par les gens qu'il
l'ait prononceront jamais parce
qu'ensuite ceux qui les prononcent ont
du mal à le faire et du mal à être
crédible pour défendre le président mais
ce que je voudrais dire c'est qu'ils
allaient texte et ya la vie les textes
disent que le président ne doit pas
abuser voilà en gros ce qui est écrit
alors les précédents présidents ils ont
passé leur temps un peu sur la frontière
c'était discutable est ce que là c'était
plus est ce que là c'était moins alors
le csa 10ème âme là c'est un peu trop
donc on vous retire là on est plus sur
la frontière on est carrément dans le
pays un pays d'à côté où on a installé
son équipement et son aéroport donc on
est au delà de tout ce qui n'est jamais
arrivé donc
ou bien le csa considère qu'on est dans
le nouveau monde et que donc tout ça
fait partie de la nouvelle vie ou bien
on considère qu' il faut intervenir pour
dire où est la limite où est la
frontière dans une zone qui est toujours
naturellement un peu grise mais qui ne
peut pas être à ce point rouge vif m
philippe gosselin oui j'en voyais réagir
aux propos de
oui oui je je je partage totalement
enfin quand le maire d'autun et qu'on
fait pression sur le csa parce que nous
saisissons le csa je lui rappelle que le
rôle d'une autorité administrative
indépendante c'est aussi de pouvoir être
saisi c'est aussi de pouvoir introduire
un certain nombre de places et c'est son
rôle c'est très clair donc il ya aucune
pression le csa est à une grande fille
qui sera capable ou une grande
institution qui sera capable de se
déterminer on verra ce qu'il en sera
maintenant il n'y a pas de pression il y
à un cadre juridique mais où
conviendrait qu il ne s'agit pas
simplement de ce cadre juridique et
qu'il ne s'agit pas non plus d'entendre
le président de la république sur sa
vision de l'inde au pacifique l'émission
est bien présenté comme un bilan le
bilan c'est celui d'un sortant c'est pas
du tout ce que vous nous vendez alors
certes je n'ai pas vu l'émission
puisqu'elle est enregistrée soit disant
dans les conditions du direct très bien
et vous voyez bien que ce n'est pas la
même chose d'avoir une émission
enregistrée dans les conditions du
direct une émission en direct ça veut
dire que certains aujourd'hui ont déjà
l'ensemble des éléments que les éléments
de langage peuvent être largement
distribués pour que en temps réel qui
soit
démultipliée ca va illustrer donc on est
encore moins sur un pied d'égalité
d'abord sur le fond il s'agit bien de
défendre un bilan un bilan avec 72
heures d'avancé pour des participants et
puis bah les autres qui vont devoir se
contenter de découvrir la règle du jeu
en cours de partie moi je n'appelle pas
ça un match à la loyale je suis désolé
vincent chauvet c'est vrai que le type
de l'émission sait où va la france on ne
sent pas vraiment
voilà une
comment dirais-je il ya effectivement
ambiguïté non déjà une différence entre
bilan et promesses on le sait quand on
d'élus locaux lé bilan de mandat sont
autorisés c'est pas la même chose que
des promesses de campagne est là et bien
il n'est pas en train de détailler son
programme pour 2022 moi je souhaite
évidemment qu'il soit candidat mais il
ya une différence entre un bilan et des
propositions de campagne et que leur
président fasse un retour objectifs sur
ces différentes actions ça me paraît pas
complètement anodin
il a ensuite le bleu je le redis le csa
n'a pas besoin des républicains pour
faire appliquer la loi à ces cétacés de
la beuze de la communication j'espère
contre parole également ce sujet et puis
enfin en france on convoque pas la
presse on invite la presse la presse
n'est pas aux ordres ne convoque pas et
je ne sais pas sur quelle planète vivent
et au réalisme j'ai l'impression que les
réseaux sociaux avaient inondé par
emmanuel mais nous on aimerait bien être
invité grt façon lancé un appel à
emmanuel macron est d'ailleurs à tous
les autres candidats alexis poulain est
vrai qu' on n'a pas cette chance sur
arte france d'être maintenant invité par
l'elysée non ne me bats système de céans
tri c'est vrai que ces voix là on on
imagine que le travail va être ardue
pour les membres du csa d'examiner
chaque parole parce que l'équipe de
communication de l'elysée va forcément
faire un effort pour masquer une forme
de bilan ou de houe de campagne n'est ce
pas évidemment tout est fait pour faire
passer cette émission pour une émission
hommage quasiment hommage à emmanuel
macron pourquoi pas tant qu'on y est
avec stéphane bern qui va nous parler
mais c'est pas nouveau enfin moi moi
j'ai en tête cette interview au pied du
sapin de noël sur le service public
pareil ou emmanuel macron faisait
visiter l'elisée je crois que c'était la
première année de son quinquennat là
aussi on est des dents dans
l'hagiographie ways face était c'était
pas le rôle d'un média de faire ce type
de reportage avec emmanuel macron on est
toujours dans la communication dans
l'utilisation médiatique à des fins de
propagande politique et c'est là où
effectivement le csl totalement
désemparé
c'est pas du tout le seul nicolas
sarkozy l'avait fait nicolas sarkozy
télé lorsqu'il était en campagne lui
aussi avait un rapport aux médias très
très très charnelle très proche françois
hollande qui a invité les journalistes à
l'elysée pour parler et raconter tout et
n'importe quoi donc il ya toujours eu un
rapport particulier mais là on sent
l'utilisation de communicationnel c'est
à dire qu'on sait très bien que ce
président est en campagne c'est inutile
de faire croire qu'il ne va pas être
candidat face à me paraît quand même du
domaine de l'impossible on sait jamais
après tout la politique s'est jamais
comme prévu mais là on est vraiment dans
quelque chose doute c'est ça aide
forcément désemparés parce que comme je
le disais il ya à la fois les réseaux
sociaux à la fois une communication
multicanal et le jeu est totalement
déséquilibré je suis désolé une élection
présidentielle c'est quel candidat a été
le plus vu par les français finalement
très peu de français connaissent
l'ensemble des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle gilles casanova
voyez réagir mais c'est de bonne guerre
si on était à la place d'emmanuel macron
certainement qu'on ferait la même chose
c'est non non parce que c'est de
mauvaise guerre pour une raison que je
vais vous donner c'est que lorsqu'on a
l'impression que le grand dans la cour
d'école maternelle ils frappent tous les
petits un parent parce qu'ils sont
petits eh bien on finit par ne plus
aimer du tout le grand mais c'est qu'on
a le droit de le faire ma foi si on a le
droit de le faire oui mais on a aussi le
droit de détester celui qui fait ce
qu'il a le droit de faire mais qui est
immoral donc si j'étais son conseiller
je lui dirai il y a une limite au-delà
de laquelle ça se voit alors il ya des
vitrines dit en même temps il est le
seul à pouvoir défendre son bilan bon ça
c'est pas un partisan d' emmanuel macron
qu'iggy nous qui nous écrit ce
télégramme philippe josselin gosselin
pardon
clairement ça a perturbé mais les nids
pécresse ou ou dans le fond ça vous
arrange un petit peu que de voir que le
président réagi parce que c'est ce que
vous nous dites qu'il réagit justement
la montée dans les sondages de votre
candidate plusieurs plusieurs degrés de
lecture d'abord il ya sur le plan de
l'immédiateté une conséquence directe
c'est la déprogrammation d'un d'une
émission qui était prévu sur une sur une
autre chaîne donc c'est quand même fâché
maintenant en réalité on voit bien la
grande fébrilité qui est derrière tout
cela on a une candidature de valérie
pécresse qui n'était pas du tout attendu
toute la stratégie élyséenne était de
miser sur xavier bertrand les
l'organisation était parti dans ce sens
là et on le sait on a des contacts avec
un certain nombre de collègues qui nous
confirme on a un certain nombre de
papiers qui dans la presse vont dans le
même sens aussi donc voilà ils sont à
l'elysée un peu un peu déboussolé un peu
inquiet donc on sent bien cette petite
fébrilité maintenant vous savez une
fébrilité de noël ne fait pas
l'hirondelle n'y pas tant donc je me
garderai bien de vous dire que les
choses sont gagnées mais là où il y a
quelque chose de bien gagner c'est que
enfin l'elysée se retrouve avec une
candidature sérieuse qui est prise au
sérieuse et qui va nécessiter un vrai
débat donc maintenant on attend nous un
match à la loyale ça sera au plus tard
le 1er janvier même si encore une fois
je conteste cette approche je
rappellerai que l'élection
présidentielle a été avancé de plus de
trois semaines par rapport à celle de
2017 et si les règles de 2017 commencer
à s'appliquer au 1er janvier il serait
logique qu'elle s'applique aujourd'hui
trois semaines en amont c'est à dire en
réalité ozanon plomb du 1er décembre et
à ce moment là le csa ne pourrait que
constater que le temps de parole de
demain soir est intégrée dans le temps
de parole du candidat macro vincent
changé sur la première partie de la
réponse de philippe gosselin celle une
station d'une forme de fébrilité du côté
de l'elysée par rapport à la devant la
candidature de valérie pécresse
donc je suis d'accord avec philippe
gosselin valérie pécresse est une
candidate tout à fait sérieuse et il
faudra que vienne le temps du débat
effectivement armes égales on a vu qu
emmanuel macron en débat notamment face
à marine le pen a été s'est révélé comme
le meilleur candidat je pense que
emmanuel macron en débats face à des
candidats de premier ou deuxième tour
sera également en capacité j'observe que
d'autres débat s'organise notamment un à
l'extrême droite c'est là où nous allons
avoir le vrai débat démocratique
aujourd'hui effectivement à part des
déclarations des uns et des autres ou
des prennent des nouvelles à kolda
socialiste un libre ou valérie pécresse
possiblement à déprogrammer mais en
accord avec la chaîne pour se re
programmer plus tard chacun fait surtout
ça sa promotion en tout cas son propre
discours la démocratie c'est aussi le
temps que les changes j'espère qu'il
viendra et il revient aux médias qui
encore une fois ne sont pas aux ordres
qu'on voit pas qui rompt intime pas de
passer de ne pas passer de tel ou tel
candidat d'organiser les débats qui
intéresseront éclaireront le choix des
français alexis poulain il n'a pas un
fond de vérité dans ce que nous dit
vincent chauvet dans le fond ça va jouer
les derniers mois donc la polémique n'a
peut-être pas lieu d'être parce que est
ce que les électeurs qui pour l'instant
aussi son ne savent pas forcément pour
qui ils vont voter ce qu'ils vont se
souvenir de cette première par leur vie
de précampagne non ils vont pas s'en
souvenir le problème d'une élection
présidentielle c'est qu'elle se fait
dans une cour de récré de 6e vous
demandez à des élèves de 6e quelles sont
les personnalités politiques qui
connaissent ils vont vous insistez 4
maximum c'est ces quatre là qu'ils vont
faire l'élection donc c'est quoi ces des
personnalités dont on parle parce qu'ils
sont médiatique parce qu'ils sont
médiatisés vous avez beaucoup de petits
candidats ou des candidats qui ont moins
de d'accès aux médias donc même s'ils ne
sont pas convoqués c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne donc aujourd'hui vous les
voyez vous les connaissez qui sont ces
candidats et ça ne va faire qu'empirer
donc cette pré campagne
elle est là pour mithridate et l'opinion
publique pour dire finalement voilà vous
savez que ça va jouer entre ces quatre
personnes et demandé un élève de sixième
si vous n'êtes rien sous la main et il
vous dira voilà les quatre qui seront
qui seront dans le dos au second tour
soit qui feront l'élection c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne malheureusement
gilles cazade avoir rajouté peut-être
quelque chose sera justement cette
élection qui passe au dernier moment
est-ce que ça compte tout ça
écoutez ça compte dans le regard que
l'on porte sur la personnalité et je
pense qu emmanuel macron a maintenant
acquis des idées traits de personnalité
assez marquée pour les français et il ne
devrait pas souligner à ce point ceux
qui sont les plus négatifs merci en tout
cas à tous les quatre messieurs finit
par goce machine casanova vincent
chauvet et alexis poulain merci d'avoir
été avec nous